INTRO:
When people think of the highest paying jobs in
the world, they generally think of top executives.
And this makes sense given that people like Sundar
Pichai and Tim Cook often pull in over a hundred
million dollars per year. But, there’s actually
one job that pays even higher and that’s being a
hedge fund manager. The top hedge fund managers
aren’t just billionaires, but they literally
make billions every single year. In 2021,
the top paid hedge fund manager was ironically Ken
Griffin from Citadel who pulled in a total of $2.5
billion. Considering this insane income, you would
think that these guys are the next Warren Buffett,
but this isn’t exactly true. At least with top
executives, they generally create a lot more value
for shareholders than they’re paid themselves.
For example, since Tim Cook became CEO,
Apple’s market cap has grown over $2 trillion.
So, it’s understandable that Tim Cook is paid
so much. But, with hedge fund managers, their
performance is generally not only mediocre,
but they often don’t even beat the market. Ken
Griffin's Citadel, for example, grew a solid 26%
in 2021. This sounds really good until you realize
that the S&P 500 itself grew 26.89% in 2021. So,
Ken basically only had average performance, yet
he received the highest salary in the entire
world. So, why are hedge fund managers paid so
much when their performance is at best mediocre.
CLIENT BASE:
To understand why hedge fund managers are paid
so much, we have to first understand what type of
person even invests in a hedge fund in the first
place. In terms of qualifications, generally, you
have to be an accredited investor and you have to
be willing to invest a minimum amount of capital
to be part of a given hedge fund. The top hedge
funds generally have even stricter requirements
given their notoriety. Citadel, for example,
requires that you have $10 million in investable
assets to join their funds. Considering this, the
average investor in hedge funds are billionaires
and institutional investors like banks, pension
funds, and retirement funds. And often, the top
priority for these guys is not capital growth
but rather risk minimization. Here’s the thing,
if you’re a billionaire, your company and/or
investments have been demolishing the market for
several years if not decades. Take Jeff Bezos,
for example. Since Amazon went public, their
stock has grown from $2 a share to about $3000
a share today after accounting for stock splits.
If we annualize this return, we get an
average annual return of over 35%. Now,
that might now sound like a lot given that
the S&P 500 already averages 7-8% per year.
But, when you compound this growth, things
get wacky extremely quickly. For example,
if you average 8% per year for 25 years, you end
up with a solid 7.34x return. But, if you average
35% per year for 25 years, you end up with a 5500x
return. Considering this, someone like Jeff Bezos,
isn’t trying to maximize returns when they invest
in a hedge fund. They’re trying to minimize risk.
This becomes even more important when you
consider that most billionaires have their
entire net worth tied up with 1 maybe 2 companies.
But wait a minute, how exactly does a hedge fund
even minimize risk in the first place? Well, one
of their risk mitigation strategies is in their
name, hedging. If you’re not familiar with what
hedging is, it’s basically buying insurance on
all of your positions by also betting the opposite
of what you think is going to happen. For example,
let’s say I’m a massive fan of Tesla and I think
it’s going to 10x from where it’s at right now.
So, I go ahead and invest $10 into Tesla. If I
wanted to hedge this position, I would spend an
additional $1 on betting that Tesla will go down.
There’s multiple ways to do this from shorting
to buying options to performing equity swaps, but
the specifics don’t really matter. All you need to
know is that this $1 position goes up in value if
Tesla stock goes down. Now, if my initial thesis
was right and Tesla does 10X, I’ll lose the $1
that I bet against Tesla, but my initial $10
investment would grow to $100 meaning that
I still profited $89. On the other hand,
if my thesis is wrong and Tesla halves in value,
my initial investment would go down to $5. But,
the $1 that I bet against Tesla might’ve grown
to $3 or $4 meaning that I’m left with a total
of $8 or $9. In this case, I only lost 20-30%
of my initial investment while the average Tesla
investor lost the full 50%. And this is really the
core of what hedge fund managers are paid to do.
BETA:
Every hedge fund has a beta value depending on
how much the given fund hedges their positions.
If a fund has a beta value of 1, that means that
their positions will perform exactly in line with
the general market. If the S&P 500 goes up 5%, the
hedge fund will also make 5% and vice versa. If a
fund has a beta value over 1, this means that the
fund is more volatile than the general market. If
the market grows 5%, such a fund may grow 10%, but
the thing to note is that, if the market drops 5%,
such a fund will lose 10%. While there are
some funds out there with a beta over 1,
this is by no means the average hedge fund. A fund
could also have a negative beta which means that
the fund is inversely correlated to the market.
But, given that markets trend up with time,
it usually makes no sense to invest in such a fund
for an extended period of time. The average hedge
fund usually has a beta between 0 and 1. This
means that the fund is correlated to the market,
but it will usually underperform the market both
to the upside and the downside. And with that
being said, take a look at this graph comparing
S&P 500 and hedge fund performance. Clearly,
hedge funds basically never beat the S&P 500, but
focus on what happens when the S&P 500 is posting
losses. Between 2000 and 2002, the S&P 500 lost
43% due to the dotcom crash. Meanwhile, hedge
funds didn’t even have a single negative year.
Similarly, in 2008, the S&P 500 lost 37% while
hedge funds only lost 22%. Now, for most people,
it would’ve just been better to hold the S&P 500
through such crashes given its superior overall
returns. But, this doesn't apply to everyone. For
example, let’s go back to Jeff Bezos. During the
dotcom crash, Amazon stock crashed 95%. And given
that 99% of his wealth was tied up with Amazon,
he was bagholding quite a bit of Amazon stock.
Considering this, would it really have made sense
for Jeff to invest the cash that he did have into
the S&P 500 and bag hold that as well? Not really.
It would’ve made a lot more sense for him to have
invested that money in a hedge fund and settled
for lower gains and more safety. So clearly,
hedge funds don’t have to beat the market for
them to be appealing in certain situations.
With that being said, it really makes no sense
to even compare hedge fund returns with the S&P
500. That’s like comparing bonds with the S&P
500 and then concluding that bonds suck given
that they have lower yields. It’s not that
one is superior and the other is inferior,
they’re simply different instruments
that make sense in different situations.
ALPHA:
If it doesn’t make sense to compare hedge fund
performance with the S&P 500 though, how should
hedge funds be evaluated? Well, the answer
is alpha. Every investment has a risk profile
which like hedge funds are described by beta. And
alpha describes how good your investment did in
relation to its beta value. In other words, alpha
is simply a way to measure risk adjusted returns.
For example, let’s say that in a given year,
the S&P 500 returned 12%. Meanwhile, you’re a
fund manager who decides to invest in Apple. You
think that Apple will outperform the S&P 500,
but Apple is a bit riskier with a beta value of
1.2. Now, let’s say that Apple ends up producing a
return of 15% which is 3% higher than the S&P 500.
By using this equation, we can determine that the
alpha of this investment was positive 1.2% meaning
that it was a good investment. In this example,
Apple stock outperformed the S&P
500 and our alpha was positive.
But, an investment doesn’t need to outperform the
S&P 500 for our alpha to be positive. For example,
instead of investing in Apple stock, let’s say
we buy an Apple bond that yields 5% per year.
While this investment has a much
lower return than the S&P 500,
it’s also much safer. And if its beta value is
low enough, the Apple bond could still produce
a positive alpha. Something to keep in mind
though is that this same logic also works the
other way around. Just because you beat the market
doesn't mean that you’ll have a positive alpha.
For example, if you produce a 100% return but
your beta is 10, your alpha won’t be looking that
great. Alpha is the primary benchmark institutions
and billionaires look at when they invest in a
hedge fund. And boasting a high alpha is usually
the number 1 goal of any hedge fund. Ray Dalio,
for example, has an entire group of funds
that are called Pure Alpha. So, next time
you see a headline that’s trashing on hedge fund
returns, don’t be fooled into thinking that these
funds are garbage. The only way to really tell if
they’re garbage or not is to look at their alpha.
COMPENSATION:
Now that we’ve discussed the true goals of hedge
fund managers and how exactly they achieve these
goals, let’s talk about their compensation. The
standard fee structure amongst hedge funds is the
2 and 20 rule. This means that fund managers
are paid 2% of the entire fund's assets under
management every single year regardless of how
the fund performs. On top of this, they receive
20% of any profit they generate. This means that
such funds have to grow over 2% every single year
just for the clients to breakeven. Fortunately,
virtually all hedge funds average a return of
at least 2% per year, but this does heavily
dampen the net returns that the clients make.
Not to mention, many of the positions that
hedge funds take are short term positions
meaning that clients have to pay short
term capital gains taxes on these returns.
Some funds do offer lower fee structures, but
basically all of the flagship funds you hear
about on the news use this structure. And
given that such funds generally manage over
a hundred billion dollars, it’s not surprising
that their fund managers walk away with billions
every year. In terms of the client’s perspective,
while it is true that these fees are quite high,
you can’t really find hedging services for
cheaper. You may be able to find better returns
for cheaper, but you won't be able to find hedging
services for cheaper given that hedging is quite
work intensive. Analysts on wall street generally
work 100 to 120 hours every single week. While
this is quite brutal, especially in the early
days when you’re not making that much money,
if you stick with it for 5-10 years, it’s quite
reasonable to earn 7 figures every year. So, if
you’re looking to make 7 figures when you’re young
and you don’t want to start a business, pursuing
wall street is likely the most straightforward
way to achieve it. With that being said though,
there is a dark side to hedge funds. In order to
achieve high alpha and minimize beta, hedge funds
often use every trick you can think of. Everything
from market manipulation and insider trading to
pump and dumps and securities fraud. Most of the
time, the SEC won't do anything about it, but
even if they do, for many hedge funds, it’s just
the cost of doing business. The perks of insider
trading and market manipulation are simply way
higher than the minuscule fines from the SEC. And,
in the end, it just comes down to one question: do
the ends justify the means. Wall street tends to
think that it does while retail traders think that
it doesn’t. Which side are you guys on? Comment
that down below. Also, drop a like if you think
wall street needs to be held more accountable.
And of course, consider checking out our
international channels to watch our videos
in other languages and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.